as members of Congress returned to their
offices here on Capitol Hill opinion on
Syria seems to be divided into at least
five groups that runs the full spectrum
of opinion from those who don't want any
military action to those who want it now
we're talking about sending a clear
message to the dictators in Tehran and
Pyongyang if we say that the use of
chemical weapons is unacceptable
yet we fail to act this will embolden
Iran's pursuit of nuclear breakout
capabilities for that group the
President had the authority to strike
Syria and doesn't need Congress to
approve it because Bashar al-assad in
launching this chemical weapons attack
he's accused of has broken all
international norms and for those
congressmen the concern is that any
delay is going to be counterproductive
and will undermine the impact of any
military action when it eventually comes
I don't regret if someone who's been
using chemical weapons against his own
people gets blown up then there are the
Hawks who want military action but think
the president's plans are too limited
they say that pinprick cruise missile
strikes as they call them won't make
much difference what they want is a
broader strategy that could last longer
and could remove the Syrian leader from
power now that feels so strongly about
that they may actually vote against the
president because they don't believe
he's going far enough
we've seen Obama administration
officials up here on Capitol Hill all
week giving hearings trying to persuade
the undecided and they are probably the
biggest group now they are grateful
they've been asked by the president to
do this they don't feel that presidents
do this enough asking Congress about
military action but it doesn't mean to
say they're going to support him
they need more persuading and more
convincing and then there's another
group of thanks for asking us
congressmen who are grateful they've
been asked but will definitely not be
supporting the president as far as
they're concerned Barack Obama has dug
himself into a deep political hole with
his redline on chemical weapons in Syria
and they're not prepared to help dig him
out of it
the last group has made up its mind on
Syria and it's against military action
as interesting combination of Tea Party
conservatives and liberal anti-war doves
and not a one not a one member in my
district in South Carolina or the emails
of people that have contacted my office
say go to Syria and fight this regime to
a letter they say no but I think it's a
mistake to get involved in the Syrian
civil war soldiers coming home to formed
and limbless and even in a body bag
is not acceptable to me the
conservatives believe America spent far
too much money sticking its military or
into bits of the world that it shouldn't
care about and on the left there are
those who say that the experience in
Iraq and Afghanistan should be teaching
the Americans lessons about Syria the
challenge for the president is trying to
persuade as many of those undecided
members of Congress not to join this
anti military action camp and the
problem for him is that American public
opinion seems to be firmly behind this
camp with opinion polls suggesting that
most Americans away from Capitol Hill
away from Washington do not want any
kind of military action in Syria